[Music]
Just when I thought spring had arrived
for good, we woke up to a blanket of
snow. The kind that doesn't stay long,
but reminds you that the seasons change
slowly in layers, not all at once. that
hill. Head high and shoulders
[Music]
back. Watching you was such a
thrill. All
[Music]
from the beginning of the April, I
started working at our local garden
center. Again, it's a small place full
of green life, soil, and that quiet hum
of people who love plants. It's still
early in the season, and the mornings
are cool, sometimes even frosty. But
there's something special about watching
the place come back to life. Most of the
work is simple. Moving plants, sweeping
gravel, tiding displays. It's physical
in the best way. Your hands stay busy,
but your mind gets to breathe. There's a
quiet written to it. Birds hung in the
background. The smell of soil and wood.
A little green signs of life all around.
I learn something new every day here.
About plants, yes, but also about
patience, presence, and the pace of
nature. It's a kind of slow magic, and
I'm grateful to be part of it.
[Music]
Hold
back. We were running on that open
shore. No saddle's
[Music]
back. I never felt so free
before. All that I could do is
laugh. I couldn't hold it back. I
couldn't hold
it. I couldn't hold it
back. I couldn't hold it back. I
couldn't hold
it. I couldn't hold it
[Music]
back. They're lay beneath the canopy.
on the gilded forest
path when an ecasy came over
me. And all that I could do is laugh.
All that I
could I couldn't hold
it. I got to hold it back.
[Music]
How can I hold it back? How can I hold
it? How can I hold it back?
[Music]
From our head to
toes, we are standing
in the
overflow. On the weekend, we took a trip
to the city. We've been wanting to plant
a row of tuya trees for a while now.
Something about evergreens feels like a
quiet protection. They grow slowly but
steadily, just like we do.
[Music]
the silver
moon, dancing like a
[Music]
maniac. Then we raced each other to the
room. All that I could do is laugh. All
that I could I could back. I couldn't
hold it. I couldn't hold it. I couldn't
hold it back.
[Music]
We also picked up a few other small
things. Oil for the terrace, crocs,
cleaning supplies I was running low on,
and a few gardening tools. I love this
part of spring when everything feels
like a fresh start, even inside the
home. Then we loaded up the car and
headed home. I was already imagining how
the toyas would look once planted. How
they'd sway in the wind and stand tall
over the years to
come. I hold
[Music]
it. Heat. Heat.
I've been trying only crying a time
do telling myself somehow we will make
it
through. I
believe you and me, we're going to be
fine.
[Music]
You've been saying maybe we should just
be
friends. All this whole black knots of
rope has made
a
mess in
between everything that we have.
[Music]
Back home, we got to work the next day.
We've been dreaming about planting this
for a while now. A soft little green
wall along the edge of the driveway.
There's something so grounding about
planting trees. They ask you to think
long term to believe in the years ahead.
It's a quiet kind of hope. We spaced
them carefully, gave them deep holes,
and tucked them in with fresh soil, a
lot of water, a pat on the root ball,
and they were home. They don't look like
much yet, but that's the magic of it.
You plant something small, and with time
it becomes something you couldn't
imagine not having.
[Music]
It's hard to believe that we're coming
undone. Getting over our fears while
we're under the
[Music]
gun. There's no making sense of the
things that they
[Music]
say. I know it better than that.
Anyway, I've been thinking maybe you
should come
back home.
We can tell them we're just seeing how
this
goes.
Everyone thinks that they know
better. All
along we had it all again.
[Music]
It's hard to believe that we're coming
undone. Getting over our fears while
we're under the
[Music]
gun. There's no making sense of the
things that they
say. I know we're better than that
anyway.
[Music]
I've been thinking maybe you should come
back
[Music]
home. The places that be you cut through
the
noise. I wish I knew. I wish I knew what
you were thinking
of. One last drink before it's time to
go
home. I had my chance, but I screwed it
up once more. It's been years and it
still kills me. Your time might be
pretty. Hold on. Don't let me
down. Hope you feel it. Just give me a
sign. I don't know. I know it
over. You feel it right. So until next
time. Hold on. Don't know. Let me
go. I want to see through the sto.
So until next time. Lost in the crowd,
but yeah, you drown out the
sound. I wish I knew. I wish I knew what
you were thinking about. Is this thing
in my head delusion or till I die? Babe,
at least wasted a chance,
right? It's been
years still kills me. Your time might be
pretty. Hold on. Don't let me
down. You feel it too.
SC
over. You feel it too. So until next
time. Hold on. Let me go.
I want to see through the
[Music]
slo. So until next time, I'll leave
alone just like that. I'm back to being
sober. We'll leave it all inside cuz
this way will never be over. You leave
alone just like that. You're back to
being sober. you feel it.
There's something about pansies that
feels like a gentle invitation to
spring. They're small but bold, braving
the last chills of the season with their
little faces turned up towards the sun.
They're one of the first flowers I
always reach for this time of year.
Hardy enough to handle a surprise frost,
yet bright enough to bring real color
back into the garden. I love tucking
them into containers by the front door
or slipping them into bare spots in the
garden beds. It's such a simple way to
live up a space and remind yourself,
yes, the gold days are ending. They come
in so many shades, deep purples, soft
yellows, gentle whites, and somehow they
always look like they're smiling. A
little joy blooming early. For me, they
mark the true beginning of spring. Not
when the calendar says so, but when
there's color in the dirt
again. Pansies are such a cheerful
little things, but they do have their
preferences. They love cool spring air
and can handle short frosts, even down
to around minus 5. It's part of what
makes them such a good early bloomer.
They like a drink about once a week,
depending on the weather, but not too
much. Their roots don't like to sit in
soggy
soil. A little plant food every other
week can help them bloom their best. And
if you pinch off the spent flowers,
they'll keep making
more. Their happiness in sunny or partly
sp sunny spots with well draining soil.
But when the heat of summer rolls in,
they start to fade. The muggy air is
just too much for them. So, for now,
while the days are still mild, I let
them shine. A short but beautiful
season. That's part of their
[Music]
charm. It gets me almost every time.
In the midst of
[Music]
summer, watching it in full
bloom always makes me
wonder when we
were when we
[Music]
were just
kid one as
fall. We held our dreams within our
[Music]
hands. It happens every time. I wonder
how. But I can see my life so clearly
[Music]
now. Dared ourselves away from
home. Further out each passing day.
Gravel road towards the
sea. I blink and I remember
you. You and
me. You and
[Music]
me. It happens every time. I wonder how.
But I can see my life so clearly
[Music]
now. I only miss you when I close my
eyes. It's amazing how much can sift in
just a week. The snow melts, the soil
softens, and suddenly your hands are in
the dirt, your eyes on the horizon. This
season is waking up slowly, and so am I.
One planted tree, one flower at a time.
There's still more to come. More seeds,
more soil, more simple choice. But for
now, this feels like enough. These early
spring days are full of motion, but not
rush. Growth is happening everywhere
slowly. Surely, and I'm learning to move
with it. Thanks for spending some time
with me in the garden. See you again
soon in part two.
[Music]
[Laughter]